salut à tous c'est pêcheur de trésor
enfin pêcheur de trésor Quentin et rasta
ne sont pas là ils sont en train de
dormir parce qu'il travaillaient tous
les deux cette nuit enfin rasta je suis
pas très sûr qu'il travaillait mais il
dort quand même aujourd'hui je suis en
compagnie de Wim et de Danny et on est
de retour sous un spot que vous avez
déjà vu on a déjà trouvé de gun ici on a
trouvé des des tas de pièces des
collections entières avec des pièces de
tous les pays de l'argent silver coins a
lot of
things
vous avez toute sa chaîne et ses réseaux
qui sont en description de la vidéo je
pense qu'on peut faire notre premier
lancer allez on voons voir ce que ce
pont nous réserve Aï
ok je vais passer de l'autre côté de la
barrière pour essayer de tirer plus fort
sans
tomber c'est bon ça c'est décollé bon
ben il y a du
lourd
ok qu'est-ce que c'est que
ça c un miroir mais il y a plus la
glace trouvé un
panneau protoxy d'azoteureusement le
panneau
estetombéand un panneau comme ça il
avait des bijou
accroch
ok j'ai quelque
chose une montre
Casio non
casino
bye bye bye
bye petit besoin
d'aide merci thank
you un stylo
je pense qu'il marche
plus
Nice
Blanque
ok bien joué un
chargeurir
char ok c'est quoi à droite une pochette
une pochette de quoi
ça ah de
lunettes ah sont pas dedans dans leabana
dommage voir ce que j'ai
ok ok encore du
protoxide
[Rires]
c'est
qu oh
look oh
ok ok
cool
leer
va trouver d'autes
se quelque
chose
yeah
one bien joué pour la collection de
franc l'autre jour il a trouvé toute une
collection de pièces de tous les pays
donc il en reste en fait son sac était à
moitié ouvert il a trouvé un couteau
d'IS ah
oui il est
beau
Nice
[Musique]
ok
super Plô puissant utilis aussi les
Magnard qui sont disponibles sur le site
de maison de la détection le promo
pêcheur de trésorre 5%
ok disque de
frein une clé
USB
elle marche encore aussi je
pense parfait
super de tout ici il y a de tout on
continue on
y
qu'est-ce qu'on a de
beau rasta me manque un
peu petite barre de
fer bien légère
ok un
vélo pas
mal il a pas de roue en plus c'est
pratique pour le
faireilleur allez j'ai quelque chose
peut-être c'est de nouveau le pneu ah
non c'est pas le pneu
W peut-être qu'il va être joli
celui regarder typ de
Pan un
sac
regard
okic de
stationner on a aussi un
stylo
Infinity j'ai quelque chose tout au
fond un poid correct j'espère que c'est
pas encore un panneau parce que j'aime
bien les panneaux
maisz en tout cas ça lâche pas bien
accroché
ok de
vélos
et ça c'est une trottinette qu'on avait
jamais vu
encore celuià c'est pour les petits mais
il est rigolo il a 4 roues allez ça part
sur facebook facebook Marketplace Moon
je vais récupérer mon
vélo c'est vrai que c'est pas cool de
laisser ses vélos dans le canal donc on
va le sortir ah il est plus ah si
il est il est
là il repart on va le rechoper une
trisième
fois cette fois-ci c'est la bonne
allez là mon petit
ok
ok ben non c'était pas la bonne ça me
saouler ce vélo ça fait qu fois qu'il
retombe et je l'ai OK écoutez les vélos
sans rouge je prends c'est plus simple
pour le faire ailleurs si ve bien lâcher
mon t-shirt
voilà
munition
full un franc
1968 on a quelque chose qui était tout
au fond j'aime bien peut-être le fusil à
pompe ça serait énorme ça serait énorme
ça l'air plus lourd que ça peut-être
encore un vélo sera pas étonnant
ici encore une
TR super encore une différente en
plus
ok
papillon joli vélo
bleu décathon encore une
incroableouverant de vélpr peuttre force
d'enlever touses vélos on va trouver les
dessous il y a une
boîte une boîte à
lettre une clé de
voiture key
forissan donc là j'ai eu une partie de
l'ordinateur une partie de l'ordi
HP et ça s'est mis à couler d'un coup
ça vient d'où
ça il a perdu son
sp
c'est une trousse ça c'est un collégien
qu' avait marre de
l'école
spotce
oh estù ch qui c'est qui a jeté sa
trousse avant d'aller au collège là
c'est quoi c'est une
vidéo
oui trés moi je dans
vid c'est
bon est où le chien il est où le chien
il arrive cet après il arriveprès ouais
on a quand même quelque chose des escu
Glac j'espère que c'est
Bos depuis le début je suis encore sur
cette plateforme sous le pont j'ai pas
bougé et ça n'arrête pas Stu and need
Dutch
help Nice than
youome welcome
[Musique]
ok j'ai un truc qui vient du
bout je dirais le poids d'un vélo mais
on va regarder ensemble ce qu'il y a au
bout de l' ok c'est un
panneau un
capot
[Musique]
ok alors là j'ai un
C
une boucle d'oreill
aussi pas mal bon elle estimenté donc
c'est pas de l'or c'est du toc mais
c'est toujours
sympa enfin j'ai retrouvé
l'ordi j' doucement parce qu'il est déjà
tombé une fois ah j'ai eu
l'ordi
Nice on a une grosse pile aussi avec ça
bonne dépollution
la trier j'ai peut-êtreetrouvver la roue
qui était retombée tout à l'heure ah
ouais avec ça il y a un
sac on va essayer de la sortir cette
fois regardez comme il a plié la
genteente et là le sac malheureusement
j'ai l'impression qu'il est vide
ouais c'est juste un sachet plastique
ément vide ah non pas
vide un téléphone
SFR nickel ok j'ai quelque chose de
lourd lesu bruit sont pas
méchants'est que c'est
ça c'est
énorme
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce
chariot oh Nice le
couteau
monsieur
donnez-moi je vais
[Musique]
vous ah
ouais bien
vu des
cuisines c'est pliable ça va coûter un
paquet de sous
ça faut juste changer les
roulettes VO le recap des meilleurs
trouvailles donc ce beau couteau aussi
qui a été fait par Wim bravo Wim Dan et
le deuxième
couteau pour
Quentin il est pas mal avec le petit
embout là
[Musique]
super encore une fois c'est la trisème à
cet endroit donc il y a peut-être
quelqu'un qui a des choses à cacher il y
a du scotch dessus
ok US biky bon écoutez c'est la fin de
cette petite vidéo enfin petite vidéo on
a trouvé déjà plein de choses merci
encore à Wim et à Dani d'être venu vous
avez leurs réseaux sociaux qui seront en
description de la vidéo et vous allez
voir d'autres vidéos avec eux puisque
Quentin va nous rejoindre et on va
continuer à pêcher l'alim cet après-midi
pour la partie 2 à bientôt